you always made me look crazy i never
said yes you do you're always defending
that you got a [ __ ] and you're
comparing me to her
jasmine is on another level it's a
little scary uh yeah she goes ballistic
on geno after having a conversation with
him about the colors in his house that
he just so happened to pick with his
ex-wife
they picked the corners together knowing
that i guess
girl mad is an understatement
she was even looking into the mirror as
she cried
that's how you know you are too deep in
your feelings we're going to talk about
it plus
ximena tells mike her ex-boyfriend is a
hit man
and although that is extremely
disturbing damn right it doesn't compare
to what she shares next that makes me
scared for not only me but you and the
children
also
kim has useman feeling her now more than
ever after his music video shoot i am so
glad i'm happy with the way kimberly
tried to help we'll get into what she
does that has usmen excited to see where
things go from here let's see what's
gonna happen
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa you
always make me look crazy let's dive
straight into jasmine exploding on geno
for honestly
no good reason
baby
ah i wasn't happy about changing gifts
yesterday at the top of the episode
jasmine is upset at geno because she
bought him some custom gifts for
christmas and all he got her was an
electric toothbrush now while he could
have kept the toothbrush we can't forget
that geno has been out of work for
months due to the pandemic and he spent
a lot of money to go see jasmine it cost
me a lot of money just to travel to
panama the flight hotel and food costs
for us uh entertainment and all that
jazz so in my opinion considering his
circumstances
him going to see her should be enough
but for some reason jasmine doesn't view
it that way so
to get him back for only buying her a
toothbrush she books this trip to an
island in panama and told gino he needs
to pay for it you need to pay for it
how much is this gonna cost
do you know oh two thousand five hundred
dollars
and guess what y'all he said yes he's
going to pay for it i wish we we could
have spoke about
the cost part of it that's cheaper than
any other trip that you have taken
before with other women
i'm not gorgeous yes they were jasmine
is going to allow her self-esteem issues
to cause her man to go broke and for
some reason geno doesn't know how to say
no i guess he's scared of jasmine's
reaction which based off of what happens
next i don't blame them what i really
want
i want you to set on fire all the stupid
things you have in your house and i'll
be 100 happy
what's the purpose for that
because you still have that in your
house all this
decoration from your ex-wife on your
walls
i don't want this stupid awful colors
who's gonna combine red and
baby blue
what was she thinking
[Music]
a red lip and a blue sports bra it's not
baby blue but close enough
instead of bashing his eggs all she has
to say is bathe i would really like to
change the colors in your house it would
mark our fresh start but no
she takes it there the colors look good
and i i believe that's my opinion but
i don't know who picked the colors
uh it was kind of like a
a combination
between us and you want me to be there
just sitting and having breakfast
looking at those colors and it's like oh
this is so lovely
is that what you want me to do i'm
waiting for it i deserve to pick up the
goddamn colors because in a few days
more than she did in seven
years
yes
she just said that
now it makes sense to me why gino acts
like he can't say no to her
you don't have to say nasty stuff like
that
why'd you defend her so much
i'm not defending her i'm just saying
there's no reason to talk bad about her
this is the same
you know
you
just call that [ __ ] stay with her you
always made me look crazy i never said
yes you do you're always defending that
goddamn [ __ ] and you're comparing me to
her
jasmine is stressing herself out this
explosion of hers scares geno
as it should
it's a little scary her emotional
instability gives me concern about her
future and on jasmine's way downstairs
she takes a good look at herself before
she goes on to cry some more
that she's so faithful
okay let it out let it out to tell me
that he likes the corner in my face they
picked the colors together knowing that
i guess
oh
jasmine seems like she's always been
this way
i'm not sure if it solely has to do with
men and how they've hurt her in the past
this might just be a personality thing i
can see her being one of those kids on
the playground who throw a fit storm off
and then come back and want to play with
everybody hey guys can i play which is
basically what she ends up doing to geno
after she eventually calms down a bit
but first she gives him a warning and
you're not allowed to say anything good
about your exes ever
they don't exist to you or i'm gonna get
crazy and things are gonna get very bad
yeah
i think he's learned his lesson and if i
lie to you a little bit jasmine goes on
to reveal her secret to geno which is
she's taking birth control while this
entire time he's thinking he's been
planting seeds for a baby baby this is
just your first treat this is the first
time we've met
do you really i mean how do you feel now
do you think you really need them
you know we are not making a family
right now
we are not ready i'm not sure why after
what just happened that's not clear as
day to geno but
jasmine's right
they have a lot to work through before
they think about bringing another human
into the equation
all right
moving on to ximena and mike first
things first remember how last week
ximena revealed to mike that she got
surgery so she can't have any more
children even though she's been leading
him on as if she could she knows that
it's always been a dream of mine well
this episode mike told ximena that he's
willing to give up his dream of having
kids of his own and raise her sons
i know right
now while this is very kind of him
i hope he takes some time to think about
it some more this trip is for both of us
to get to know each other better to ask
us anything we want all right let's get
into this hitman conversation because
it's
crazy as ximena and mike are off on a
mini vacay in colombia she tells him her
ex who she thought was just a tattoo
artist at first turned out to be a hit
man
[Music]
but then she reveals that after she
found out about his job and broke up
with him he threatened to kill her oh
hell no
[Music]
she said he made the threat to kill her
two years ago but
that is nothing to play with so mike is
nervous
that makes me scared for not only me but
you and the children
are you absolutely sure that he's not
gonna come back and hurt any of us
[Music]
it's just one thing after another after
another
and
i'm worried right now what else i might
learn
what else might
come to light
right
something i've learned is that having a
partner just to say you have somebody is
not worth your peace of mind if i'm in a
relationship that's causing me more
stress worry and concern then peace
i'm
damn skippy i am out
you have to listen to your intuition if
it doesn't feel right it's not right and
it's just not worth it
[Music]
all right finally kim gets to see soulja
boy in action this episode usman finally
shoots his music video for zara which by
the way kim still has no idea that this
song is about his ex
you deserve way better than this
yeah just take this home but anyway
during the shoot kim steps into boss
lady mode because according to her ann
uzman his manager badmiss and assistant
slam t
are slacking
cause this just seems like really
unorganized it's terrible don't worry
i'm embarrassed for him i'm excited for
the beautiful shoot it's just that i'm
having some
you know lack of
competency from my team
which i'm not happy with that
but kimberly she's trying so hard and i
really appreciate what she's doing
okay action also surprisingly kim does
not get jealous seeing the model all
over usman she was even able to give him
a boost when he needed it so how do you
see silver
you're doing really good
your team however which is crazy to me
i'm not happy with the three things that
that is why i'm able to use in the
energy but like no don't lose the energy
that's what i came here for you're doing
just there's this picture like you're
doing this for me you invited me down
here to do this yeah seriously i'm gonna
cry if you don't promise me yeah i'm
ready
i am doing it kimbally no cute well once
the shoot wraps and this around for the
[Music]
day usman opens up about how he's
impressed by the way kim handled herself
and she was all smiles of course
today should
make my feelings about kimberly improve
i am so glad i'm happy with the way
kimberly tried to help
this shows to me that i did the right
thing
by inviting her here
and um i'm more excited to see how
things continue going let's see what's
gonna happen
[Music]
yeah let's see if he's going to end up
in kim's room because you know that's
what she's gunning for
and next week it looks like she might
make some progress once again might i
came here oh look at usman with the hat
i came here to watch you in your video
but i came for another reason too
i want to see the big picture you know
the casino want to see them sleeping in
my bed i really want you to stay with me
in your room yeah usman never fails to
surprise us so who knows he might end up
in there
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because as usual we are
covering it all i will see you next time
[Music]